hello good morning welcome to Comic-Con
and uh yeah so I'm Harold I'm CTO and
I'll be walking through our drive to
Taco Bell last year we drove to Taco
Bell with
one of our open pilot cars in uh mostly
end-to-end system I'm gonna be walking
through that and just general stuff that
research is working on
so
to start off with I'm gonna
just recap some uh oh I got a mouse
pointer over there let me uh that one
out
uh to recap basically what I talked
about two years ago which is our general
architecture for a self-driving system
so our goal at research is to make a
superhuman driving agent so someone that
can drive a car better than a human can
and
we have a few particular constraints
that we're using to do this
first of all we want to do it completely
end to end so by end to end
we mean that we want to put in sensor
data into a neural network so like video
and potentially other sensors but
predominantly video
and get driving decisions out and have
the system Drive
the big reason for this is that this
gives more flexibility to the machine
learning model to learn behaviors and
patterns itself without being
constrained by for example a perception
layer or some kind of other hand-coded
stuff in between the system
secondly it's really important that we
build solutions that scale well with
compute
a large part of society is working on
constant constantly improving the amount
of compute that is available and when
the next Generation computers come out
and the next generation's gpus are ready
to train models you want your system to
get better as a result of that and so
end-to-end training is one way to get
that because there's no hand-coded
constraints
but there are some other things we need
too such as a really good loss function
and enough diversity in the data
diversity of the data we have we have
plenty of users we have much more than
we know what to do with
and then also you need a good simple
loss function that reflects good driving
so a clear example of the victory of
this strategy is recent improvements in
llms they have an extremely simple loss
function a generally quite simple
architecture and they have now
demonstrated incredible ability over the
last few years
two years ago when I gave this talk
there were still some serious players
doing very classical things in
self-driving but honestly today nobody
takes bounding boxes seriously anymore
and everyone is moving to end-to-end
type systems
so I just want to end this introduction
with the quote from Rich Sutton who has
a very
um
relevant blog post from a few years ago
where he described this effect and he
talks about the great power of general
purpose methods methods that continue to
scale with increased computation even as
the available computation becomes very
great and this was before the llm
Revolution and as you can see he
predicted this very accurately
okay so that's kind of the basic
overview of what we're trying to build
so we can break this system down into
three basic parts
first we have end-to-end lateral control
which is basically just controlling the
steering based on the video end-to-end
longitudinal control which is
controlling the gas and the brakes based
on the video of the scene and then the
last part is to actually get to the
place that you want to go you need to
put in a destination so humans usually
use Google Maps or something like that
and they look at the video of that as
well as the road scene to kind of make
driving decisions so that's something
we're going to have to do too and as you
can see here this is how that would work
the model just sees this as well as this
and then it can get you to your
destination
let me open my water bottle here
so
Taco Bell
as a kind of proof of concept of these
three parts coming together and showing
that with an end-to-end system that has
no intermediate perception layers
doesn't have any code related to Lane
lines or traffic lights can actually do
something like drive from point A to
point B we set ourselves a challenge at
the beginning of last year which is
driving from
downtownish where old office was to a
local Taco Bell it contains just some
normal diversity of driving Maneuvers
like some some right turns and some
exits on-ramps Lane changes all that
stuff and we said we're going to do that
by the end of the year without a
disengagement on our device on a comma 3
just in a normal production car which
was rev6 and opened completely open
source so anyone can see what we did and
by the end of 2022.
so we got a very
reasonable question is that going to be
an Elon time or real time
but
for those who've been following along it
is real time by the end of 2022 we have
posted you know the full drive all the
logs and all the code
so let's go through how we actually did
that so back to those three parts those
are the three parts we need to implement
and if they work reasonably well it will
work as a proof of concept and it will
drive us to Taco Bell
so let's start with the end-to-end
lateral this is what the majority of my
talk was about last time talking about
the technical challenges involved with
doing something end to end
um
so
what we basically train on is human
driving behavior we train models to
predict where humans will drive we can
predict like curvature your rate or
points in space it's all kind of
equivalent
that by itself is not enough to train a
system because you need it to be able to
recover from noise and deviations and
mistakes so that's why
we had to train it in a simulator and we
have to introduce noise and teach it
recoveries
and then for the simulator to actually
be able to instill behavior in all kinds
of driving and to just scale with
compute and data we need to make sure
that this simulator reflects the full
diversity of the real world so we
constrain ourselves to using a simulator
that's based on real data and we have
a method for doing that which I
explained in in two years ago
which is by augmenting real data to make
it seem like you're moving around
and I tried really hard to get a picture
where I didn't look stupid from last
talk but that was actually very
difficult
so lateral's done that was two years ago
back then it was still kind of in Alpha
mode people could choose to opt in or
not opt in to end-to-end lateral control
they could revert to the Lane line
policy if they wish but today the only
thing we ship is the completely
end-to-end policy there's no logic based
on Lane lines it just drives based on
human behavior
so that's done
so let's talk about the second part
which is uh end-to-end longitudinal
so when we designed the lateral system
we always had longitudinal in mind it
was obviously never supposed to be
designed specifically for lateral but we
were focusing on the challenges involved
specifically with lateral first but
always keeping in mind to expand this to
longitudinal later
so most of the architecture worked
exactly the same for lateral as
longitudinal
instead of predicting
instead of it being your rate and
curvatures that are relevant to predict
you predict speeds and positions and
accelerations but those together with
lateral come into like a complete plan
of where to be in 3D space
so we can plug this into the simulator
that was successful for lateral but we
immediately start to get some issues
which is our simulator was pretty
rudimentary it used as you can see here
this is how it would work we would warp
the image basically sideways essentially
we were assuming that everything in the
scene was on the road plane and we were
warping it to be consistent with that
but that means that everything in the
background all the cars kind of warped
sideways and that actually wasn't that
big of a problem for lateral because the
road is what matters most but for
longitudinal you can see it's a lot more
extreme
so we need to do something about these
simulator artifacts the model can't
learn intelligent behavior when there is
so much artifacts in the simulation
so this brings us to how do we make the
simulator better to basically
make the background reproject well when
we move around and also other cars
we have a rudimentary segment that we
use for
a variety of things it's it's uh
predicts a very minimal set of classes
doesn't have any bounding boxes it just
predicts a something part of the road
part of the background part of your car
or part of other movable things
and you can see that working in this in
this scene right here
so you can quickly start to make some
pretty rudimentary assumptions about
what these things are and what how far
away they are just on what they are so
the road is generally relatively flat
and continuously flat and form some kind
of plane the background often sticks up
straight up and so do most of the cars
so with that
with those assumptions and a very
accurate understanding of the road plane
we can actually kind of guess put in a
depth for all these objects based on
that and it won't be super accurate and
especially won't be accurate for things
in the background but the most important
things are the things in the immediate
background and um
and the cars on the road and because we
have very good road plane estimation
we can actually do this quite well
so you can see this in
in action here so this is what it was on
what we trained the lateral models on
two years ago and then with the new
assumptions you can see you can see some
artifacts here for example but the
models really see a kind of abstract
version of this and so they capture most
of the behavior especially because
things on the road are perfectly
reproduced which are for all kind of
driving the most important
so we plug that all in we do the same as
lateral we train some models make them
bigger try some stuff and that works
you can see here this is what we posted
around the time we started having
successful experiments
on our ev6 just coming up to traffic
lights it uh you know slows down speeds
up appropriately and it's also
surprisingly human in doing this despite
us not having to hand code any kind of
smoothness or controls related things to
achieve that it just knows from human
behavior what a reasonable approach to a
stoplight looks like when it's either
red or orange or green
so again this is completely end to end
there is uh no traffic light code that
achieves this this is just learn how to
do gas and breaks from Human driving
so just a little fun side note on that
there is actually traffic light code in
our internal code bases
but it runs this traffic light in our
meeting room that we can over the
Internet change colors on but yeah so
that's the only traffic light code in
the comma code base everything that
makes your car stop at traffic lights is
learned end-to-end behavior from machine
learning models
so that sounded really easy I just gave
you one quick fix to our simulator and
it went from less crappy to from crappy
to a little bit less crappy and all of a
sudden we have something that stops at
red lights and stop signs now is it
really that easy uh well no because it
took us two years and also no one else
has really done this so it can't be that
easy
so I just want to talk about
even though these ideas are extremely
simple and the solutions are also very
simple to the problems we're facing
actually implementing this and
developing a shippable system ends up
having a lot of challenges and several
things that cost a huge amount of time
so the first problem is we build an
end-to-end system because it's extremely
robust it can learn driving behaviors
even if the ground truth is noisy even
if the ground with is completely wrong
for example if we were to just take one
percent of the driving images and flip
them upside down
the models would still learn to dry if
we were to reverse some of the videos
the models would still learn to drive
but the problem comes in when in start
to start to see regressions in some of
the edge cases and it's not entirely
obvious so you need extremely good tests
and infrastructure and tools to
understand how good your models are and
which things affect it so that you don't
have these little subtle regressions
that don't cause obvious failures but
overall regress the performance of the
system
and over these years we've found
hundreds and hundreds of these types of
bugs that will completely break some
tiny percentages of the ground truth and
every time we improve them everything
gets slightly better
another thing is all these things rely
on extremely accurate Road plane
estimation so we need to understand the
curvature of the road and the pitch of
the road and exactly how high the car is
above the road and all those things
without that you also start to get
pretty serious issues
but I think where we spend most of our
time is in the code we delete the things
we refactor to make them simpler and the
bad ideas that we have try and then have
to reject and completely delete
it's always a continuous fight against
complexity that's what we focus on most
on comma we want to reduce complexity
keep the solution simple and manageable
because that's how you can have a good
chance of finding as many bugs as
possible and not being susceptible to
this issue where you have this large
robust ml system that we constantly have
bugs give it bugs to and subtly regress
Behavior overall
and as a proof that this is a pretty
good strategy we have a really tiny team
working on this stuff and we have a
pretty small code base yet with that
we've managed to ship end-to-end systems
that as far as I know no one else has
and especially none that are
commercially available so this is
clearly effective
to give you an idea of how tiny the team
is everyone from the research team and
infrastructure team except our newest
hire is giving a presentation today so
that's how small the team really is
so since I spent so little time on what
the actual solution was to end to end
long because it really was quite simple
I want to give you some ideas on the
things that we really did spend time on
and that cost a huge amount of time
so first of all we spent a probably over
half of last year doing a really big
refactor
now I'm not going to go into the details
of explaining exactly what this refactor
means because the original architecture
didn't really make sense to begin with
which is why we had to refactor it and
if I tried to explain it today I don't
think I would understand it myself
but basically the system that we had
shipped to achieve end-to-end lateral
planning had many steps it included
included student teacher approaches it
included different types of architecture
that work together and it had many
stages of ground truth thing
and it was just difficult to move away
from that because it was very effective
it was deployed in the in the field and
if we wanted to refactor it we had to
make sure that the new simpler version
was just as good and theoretically it
should have been but it just took a
serious amount of effort and testing and
refactoring to get there
but after a little bit over six months
of work we managed to do that
um
we were able to take the training time
down from at the time around five days
from beginning to end with all the
models we needed to just two days
we had four models before that needed to
be trained all necessary uh that we
could reduce to just two models so now
it's just a vision model which takes in
scene compresses it to an intermediate
space and then a policy model that
actually makes the driving decisions
and this was somewhere in the middle of
last year or even a little bit before
that and since then infrastructure
improvements and other optimizations
have taken this trading time down from
two days to much less than one day and
uh Greg will be talking about that more
too
so that's a really big deviation by the
way from what many other people are
training training models in one two days
is not really that common in machine
learning world but something we feel
very strongly about because it allows
you to iterate very quickly and correct
mistakes very quickly whereas if your
training run takes three weeks that
means you know in one year you can fix
50 bugs which is not that great
um
so that was a positive thing that we
spent a lot of time on there's also some
things that we wasted a lot of time on
first one was actually one that seemed
like a great idea last Comic-Con and
that we were advertising as something
that was going to give good results soon
uh which is stop lines
so you can do end-to-end longitudinal by
just predicting speed and acceleration
or you can you can kind of
find places that the human stopped and
then say this is like a place to stop
and try to stop for that place we
already had Logic for lead cars that
tell us how to stop in a place pretty
smoothly so we thought this would be
pretty easy to implement
but in reality even though it's very
easy to predict these places to stop
with the model you end up seeing that
not all places to stop are built the
same people stop very decisively for a
crosswalk uh
very decisively for a rail road crossing
not so decisively for a stop stop sign
on an empty road for example
so the end to end is a much better
approach here and as soon as we even
within like two weeks of trying to
replace the stop line logic with end to
end we saw it showed way smoother
Behavior around these things and way
more comfortable
so probably wasted a few months on that
and then the other thing is depth Nets
so
the solution I showed earlier was
basically estimating the depth of the
road plane for simulation
making some basic assumptions about the
background and other cars and then
reprojecting to simulate
and that sounds extremely simple that
sounds like it's too stupid and really
what you should be doing is have a large
machine learning model that predicts
accurate depth of everything in the
scene and then you won't have all these
weird artifacts that I was showing
earlier
so that sounded like a good idea to us
and we spent a few months training
training models that did this and they
did predict depth relatively well
but they were still quite noisy they
weren't as accurate to understand the
road plane without the assumption that a
road plane is flat and continuous there
was a lot of inaccuracies there and as I
mentioned that's a really critical part
and also in the things that it should
have been way better at like the
background you start to see these Halos
around stuff in in depth
and then beyond that you start to even
get more issues which is what's the
depth of the light that comes out of a
lantern
I mean that's it there's no real answer
to that the depth of a pixel isn't
necessarily a real concept it makes
sense in many cases but as soon as you
start talking about shadows and
Reflections and all that sort of stuff
it breaks down and when we were doing
stuff with depth Nets we actually were
finding a lot of issues related to
lighting that were causing problems in
the other approach so we weren't even
going to fix those with the depth Nets
so after a few months of that we
completely abandoned this approach
so that's end-to-end longitudinal done
as you can see it was
mostly bug fixes mostly little cleanup
there was hundreds of bugs that we fixed
that I I didn't talk about and then some
big stuff like these refactors and then
just the slightly improved simulator and
that's what produces the end-to-end
longitudinal behavior that we ship today
in experimental mode
so that's done
and then the third part which is we have
to actually put the map into the model
the idea here is extremely basic which
is uh we have some video of navigation
feed just like Google Maps we show it to
the model and the model can understand
which driving actions to make by seeing
which the humans made to get to a
certain place Mitchell's got a whole
talk about this later and about the
challenges in testing and actually
shipping something like that
and as of two days ago we released
end-to-end navigation uh as part of
experimental mode
so that's also done
so now we're starting to get pretty
close to having something that we think
we can try this Taco Bell attempt on
there's a couple more things that we
ended up doing uh so we've got the model
here that's uh basically what I've been
talking about so far
we have some other controls stages what
we call a planner is essentially a
controls layer
and that needed some changes to
accommodate high angle rate turns and 90
degree turns that's in release that's
not in the state that was necessary
um another thing we did is we
conditioned the model on aggressiveness
of drivers so the idea was if we
classify every driver as either being
smooth and conservative or aggressive we
can also tell the model at runtime to
drive like a conservative driver or like
an aggressive driver and we did that for
the Taco Bell run so that it would drive
more like a conservative driver and go
slower through the turns and just
generally be more comfortable
and then the last thing is uh we did map
based Lane changes so the lane changes
are completely end to end we just say do
like a human would but to trigger the
lane changes we uh used the mapbox logic
that said in which lane to be and if
there's an exit coming up
so that's just four commits that code is
still open
you can you can go look at that code the
logs of the driver public and the models
are end-to-end as we intended and
there's only a couple other things that
we had to change
and so December 15th we ordered our food
from Taco Bell
and uh completed our challenge
so I'm just gonna play the video here
for a second
I'm gonna attempt to speed this up which
is very high risk
okay
that went pretty well
so as you can see it starts in the city
there's some
just some normal stop and go traffic
with some traffic lights that it does
fine and does the on-ramp here
then there's a short section on the
highway so you can see that lane change
it made there was based on the
on the map-based logic so openstreetmap
said you're on the on-ramp so switching
to the lane and then same here there's
an exit coming up make some Lane changes
to the right
um yeah and then there's just a few
minutes on the highway take the off ramp
there's some turns here
and I think there's just a final turn
coming up and then we'll see Taco Bell
in The View
so just this left turn and then Taco
Bell should be right there
somewhere
all right there we go all right so that
was our
[Applause]
thank you thank you
so that was a demo uh we make final
demos a lot because they there's a
massive difference between shipping
something and having a demo of something
and the Taco Bell Drive was a demo like
I said earlier we wanted a proof of
concept of the systems that we intend to
ship working together
but that's only the beginning we then
still have to go through the effort of
making this stuff actually
um
usable and comfortable and reliable
and that's way more work beyond the demo
so I think we did maybe about a dozen
drives I think once we had the models
that we wanted and all the end parts
there's a whole bunch of reasons why we
did redid drives sometimes we had camera
issues sometimes open pilot was too slow
sometimes open pilot didn't take the
exit
um
and actually I think about 30 of our
drives uh were unusable because there
was a whole bunch of trash on the
on-ramp that some car dropped and uh
that that was about four drives ruined
until we waited for the city crew to
clean up
so
it did it it can do it it's end to end
but there's still work to be done
so when will it actually be good so we
have experimental mode people can use
end-to-end long
um
it's about 22 percent of people that use
it today
and you know it still has flaws but some
people prefer driving with it
so if we look back at the situation of
end-to-end lateral control we can go
back two years I found this message in
our slack Deep saying we have 16 point a
lot of numbers of people who were using
laneless at the time and currently we're
already higher for end-to-end loan so
that's pretty promising
what you can also see in this image is
how our metrics changed over two years
from uh slack messages to a real
dashboard and
something that we can track over time
so some interesting things to point out
end-to-end longitudinal is very relevant
at low speeds and you can see here that
the engagement numbers are significantly
higher at the lower and mid speeds than
without
end-to-end longitudinal but then in the
on the highway there's still stuff that
we're trying to improve if the model
decides to drive too slow people will
generally disengage and drive faster so
that's one of the things that we're
working on fixing for end-to-end lawn
so this engagement minutes is a bit
higher than it is for normal driving
normally it's about 25 to 27 and in
Miles uh I think now we're hitting about
55 to 60 percent of miles are engaged of
open pilot users so that's the majority
of our users driving is driven by open
pilot
uh and then that's two of the three
parts and then the third part is
navigation which is released two days
ago so
when will it be good well if the past is
anything to go by which it should be
then in the next two years we'll be
getting these numbers to 100 and all
cars will be driving to Taco Bell
[Applause]
so that's what we've done so far I'm
going to talk a few few quick notes
about what we're working on next
so we keep talking about end to end we
even have hats that say end to end and
end-to-end machine learning is really
the core of what research stands for we
want the models to do as much as
possible to do as much as possible
internally to make everything as simple
as possible and have all the difficulty
be dealt with by the gradient Descent of
the model training this is an extremely
effective strategy and the last few
years have really driven this point home
with things like gbt4
so we still have a simulator that's hand
codes of physics we estimate the depth
with some rudimentary assumptions we
reproject that's not great we want to
have machine learning models that can
simulate for us that's something that
you've seen we'll be talking about later
we still have classical controls the
controls is quite smart and does a lot
of learning which vivec will be talking
about later
but it's not machine learning so
that's something that we can improve
eventually we will need reinforcement
learning uh it's it's normal for them
all to need to do something to do some
driving with your car to get used to it
that's how humans drive too and should
improve over time so that's something
we're looking into
and then finally a little bit more long
term
every time one of our users disengages
they're giving a signal that they would
prefer to drive an open pilot that's
something that we want to feedback on
because that means our system did
something uncomfortable or undesirable
and so in the future we want to feed
those signals back directly into
training and have the models learn to
optimize how to make the people happy
so and then if we zoom out a little bit
more
we can think what's an even more General
and more end-to-end approach than just
focusing on driving
so driving is a subset of Robotics
there's you know Ada systems or some
robotic system you have even a bit more
Niche you have like the self-driving
race cars but you know there's also just
general purpose Robotics and they share
a lot of things in common uh interacting
with the real world understanding
actuators and you know friction and
physical limits and that's something
that as self-driving systems improve
will become more and more relevant there
too
and this at first may seem a bit weird
to think like that you can make a more
effective system easier with a
completely General approach than you can
with something hyper specific but just
to give recent examples again anyone
who's making machine learning models
specifically to be a medical doctor or a
lawyer is now completely outshined by uh
gbt4 and nobody that was working on gpd4
was specifically optimizing for that
they made a general purpose language
model and it beat everything specific
and so it's not unreasonable to think
that that's how robotics will play out
too so we want to keep zooming out and
thinking are there general purpose
robotics methods that will be very
effective in self-driving in the same
way as general purpose language models
we're good at domain specific things too
so
along that axis on stage we've got Billy
and silly their little side project that
we've just been working on
the comma 3 is a great development
platform it has
good compute for machine learning it has
a screen microphone sensors kind of
everything you need in a robot very
similar to a human head and the only
thing that's missing to do robotics
experiments is to put some wheels on it
so we do sell those Wheels it's very
much a dev kit but we've been having fun
with it over the weekends so just kind
of experiment with some kind of Robotics
type things and see how well the comma 3
holds up and if there's anything
interesting we can learn from that
so I think it was a couple weeks ago
some of the research Engineers went to a
hackathon uh with Billy and silly and
they uh won second place doing some just
some things with llms talking and taking
a picture of you and printing it
so
more on a little bit of uh fun fun
robotics with comma 3 we're going to do
a hackathon at the office it's going to
be some kind of indoor navigational
challenge can we use you know machine
learning to navigate indoors you know is
that similar to driving outside that's
the kind of stuff we want to explore uh
we'll probably have some like obstacle
course indoors and have people try to
get some kind of speed run through that
it's going to be the whole weekend at
the end of September we'll do like 20 30
people if you want to come you should
apply and we'll select 20 30 people from
that and we'll post more details about
that later
it's going to be at our office which is
super cool we moved into a new office
last year it looks a bit like a compound
and has a fountain so if you're
interested in robotics hackathon
definitely check it out
and that was it for me so let's move
over to questions
[Applause]
all right I'll be doing some walk around
q a does anyone have any questions all
right we'll start up here
oh uh so I was just curious where to
navigate on uh open pilot uh I saw that
in the video it was doing fully
autonomous Lane changes but uh as far as
I I'm aware like uh looking in the code
and on my own custom Branch I don't see
that
um it's actually it's only using the
blind spot sensors on my Toyota 2020
Toyota Corolla but it's not using the
railroad facing camera so
um if it's only using the blind spot
sensor that but the blind saw sensor is
not like a hundred percent like um
effective right um so how safe it would
would it be to do those Lane changes
which is so it's still an ADA system so
you're expected to pay attention any
time so for example in a Taco Bell Drive
you can see that I'm checking the blind
spot monitors for those Lane changes
yeah and I mean that's kind of what
we're imagining and also this is true
for all of open pilot driving for the
foreseeable future you need to supervise
it so yeah the expectation is we'll make
we can make Lane changes when we think
it's a good idea but there's still some
burden on the
on the user but that aside in the future
we are going to use the both the
interior facing camera and the blind
spot monitors uh to check this so it
should become more reliable when we move
to that but we haven't shipped that yet
oh okay gotcha and just uh one more
small question like does that work on
every because um in the DBC file I I
don't see like Lane chain or the
indicator status so yeah that's going to
be car specific and then the interior
facing camera will be uh on all cars
obviously
hi two questions did you go to the
retreat after you delivered Taco Bell
Drive so it's planned for October
but it's real it's always planned for
October and the second question as far
as I understand the enter and long
doesn't give anything specific attention
to speed limits right no it doesn't so
like I'm from I'm from Europe and like I
know that here you can make a pretty
good guess in States like what the speed
limit is going to be in Europe it's a
mess right so I mean that's going to
change in the future
just just like Europeans users need to
pay attention Lane changes to speed
limits open parallel world 2 and in the
future we'll add that as an input it's
just not the priority right now
um for depth prediction in the simulator
have you considered or tried out using
neural Radiance fields or anything
similar to that before
so I didn't train the depth Nets you can
you see and did those
but just generally speaking
we we didn't see a future in that
approach the concept of depth just
doesn't scale towards the end and so
even if we had perfect depth Nets we
didn't see a solution so we were
actually dealing with a lot of issues
which is
so you've got headlights of your car
they illuminate the road in front of you
and when you start augmenting the video
you need to augment those lights too and
a depth net can never help with that and
that's the real reason why we gave up
not because we we were confident
obviously you can get better and better
models but not that we can solve this
concept of depth to make a good
simulator
hi uh is the model trained entirely on
simulated data or is there any fraction
of real world camera data too uh so
it's trained entirely on simulated data
but the simulated data is all real video
that is augmented okay there is no
actually simulated there's no like pure
simulation data
like like Unity or something like that
anyone else down here
oh yeah thank you for the presentation
um so you know I think a lot of the
questions around like hey
this doesn't seem like it's ready for
like general public driving prime time
but this is still quite an impressive
system are there narrower applications
that are now much closer to being kind
of production ready
twice or
uh yeah with and self-driving so say for
example you can't drive on a public road
but could you drive around a mining site
for example
oh I mean I guess but yeah we're just
not really interested in that we want to
make a really good Ada system and kind
of expand on this robotics
AI future I guess
uh can you talk a little bit more about
some of the techniques uh for the
end-to-end nav with the map like for
instance keeping it at like a static
zoom level versus zooming in as you get
close to terminal presentation about
that later this morning and we'll go in
a lot of detail and that's why I glossed
over it very quickly okay I have some
more questions uh if that's okay
um can you talk about maybe some of the
challenges with disengagement analysis
for cars that don't have op long
um you know how do you detect it's a
disengagement for just a failure of the
stock ACC versus an actual open pilot
you know uh long I mean we know whether
they're using stock lock so I mean
obviously we we know that context when
we're looking at the disengagements
right we know if it's their system or
not so that's that's not an issue
there's actually some some disengagement
analysis uh talk coming also later and
wishing well we'll give some insight
into that as well okay one more question
related to that
um you know is is it a training day that
you should get more useful from cars
that have op long enabled or you know do
you still use it for cars that don't
have op long enabled that are using the
stock ACC so training data the way we
train the models now not necessarily but
as a kind of feedback for us as the
engineers to understand how the system
is being used and where it's failing
it's more useful when you have op long
but again it's not training the models
it's training us but I don't know is
that kind of that's kind of the same
thing in the end
[Applause]
world